captain wake up something has happened
halo wars 2 lies somewhere in between an
RTS game for Halo fans and a Halo game
for RTS fans it adapts halos FPS roots
well taking the series best missions and
reformatting them in ways that makes
sense for a strategy game without
sacrificing accessibility but ultimately
this is a very light RTS experience
geared towards Halo veterans not a
robust strategy game and it runs out of
steam quickly Halo Wars 2 takes place
nearly three decades after Halo Wars 1
and chronologically after halo 5 the
crew of the spirit of fire emerges from
cryo sleep and is now taking on a rogue
brute faction called the banished rather
than the covenant the story is important
to the set up of each battle and
interesting enough as a Halo fan but you
could mostly tune it out and you
wouldn't miss too much there are however
some really gorgeous cut scenes that
make following along worthwhile and they
drew me back into the Halo universe the
grav lift what do we do you you hold on
Halo Wars twos campaign is at its best
when it borrows from its FPS source
material a warthog sequence in the first
mission feels like a bird's-eye version
of the warthog runs in combat Evolved in
three and the mission structure is
comfortably familiar slower missions
with snipers are booked ended by chaotic
horde battles and what feels like a
typical halo campaign played from a
different perspective
rather than an RTS in its own right
routing LZ for the grad live now wait we
got hostiles
going down the multiplayer also takes
tried-and-true Halo FPS modes and adapt
them for an entire army domination games
which involve capturing and holding a
location like the territories mode in
two three in reach or an arms race
requiring a lot of resource management
although some games can run on the
longer side a lot of matches aren't too
time intensive which is good if you're
more used to dropping in for a few brief
rounds in an FPS both the multiplayer
and the campaign feature quicker more
explosive clashes over drawn-out
struggles for supremacy and they pair
well with Halo Wars twos more simple RTS
elements but Halo Wars 2 can often feel
too stripped-down to be truly strategic
on the one hand it's accessible but the
campaign is only challenging in the
final few missions once I'd figured out
which kind of units to build which is
really the main strategy element at the
core of every battle I could basically
send all my troops to one location for
an attack
it was often easier and more effective
to just DoubleTap the right bumper to
select all of my units rather than try
to separate them by unit type and form a
truly organized offense the few times
that was necessary I felt like I really
earned my victories but its overall too
limited to be truly satisfying
[Music]
in multiplayer the only important
decision to make is which of several
leader powers to pick otherwise the UNSC
and banished factions offer pretty
similar tactical opportunities matches
are generally hectic enough to be fun
but the streamlined FPS inspired nature
of battle is only entertaining for so
long
once you've ironed out a general plan of
attack and gotten resource management
mastered there's not much left to
discover or adapt to blitz mode is
interesting if not a huge draw putting
an RTS spin on halos deck building card
game of course without a solid RTS
foundation for the game at large that
doesn't mean much for blitz and like the
rest of Halo Wars - it doesn't have legs
isabell lawns Archer missiles now
that's not gonna hold them back sir
as a longtime Halo fan Halo Wars 2 has
just enough to pull me in but not enough
to keep me coming back it's palatable
for those used to the FPS taking
inspiration from favourite missions and
putting a strategic spin on them but
just when things become more challenging
and actually interesting it runs out of
steam
izabel what do we do